the concept of the exterior angle of a
triangle is quite easy to digest to get
the exterior angle we can extend any one
side of the triangle mm let's say we
extend this one there we go we have the
exterior angle of our triangle let's
call it D in this case angle a and angle
B will be its interior opposite angles
and this angle will be its interior
adjacent angle the only concept we
really need to understand here is the
relation between the triangles exterior
and its interior angles in this triangle
D will be the sum of a and B using words
we can say that the exterior angle will
always equal the sum of its interior
opposite angles take this example for
instance we are asked to find the value
of x this angle here is the exterior
angle and it will equal the sum of X and
70 as they are its interior adjacent
angles solving this we get the value of
x as 60 degrees in fact there is another
thing we can deduce looking at D is
equal to a plus B D will always be
greater than a and D will also be
greater than B the exterior angle will
always be greater than each of its
interior angles and if we call the
interior adjacent angle C then we can
say that C and D form a linear pair
which means their sum will be 180
degrees okay how about we form another
problem to see if we have actually
understood the concept of exterior
angles let's form three lines line a
line B and line C you're given that this
angle is 130 degrees this one's 55
degrees
and this one's why how do we find the
value of y pause the video and give it a
try it's the same concept of exterior
angles just that it's not very direct
this time this angle is vertically
opposite to angle Y as vertically
opposite angles have equal measures this
angle too will measure Y now it's easy
this is an exterior angle and these two
are its interior opposite angles so 130
degrees will equal 55 degrees plus y and
we get the measure of Y as 75 degrees
you